hey guys Peter Rubin senior editor wired
here with our special comic-con
correspondent Cara Santa Maria and a
hearty congratulations to you for
surviving the second of four days of
comic-con I went to the floor and it was
really cool because i was on a hunt for
the most expensive thing at comic-con
was in a robot I'm not telling was it a
picture of a room I'm not telling we
made a really cool YouTube video you've
got to check it out it's on the wire
channel I will do that as always we had
a ton of people coming through wired
cafe so we had we had a surprise
appearance from kevin eastman the
co-creator of teenage mutant ninja
turtles which for me was just
unbelievable there was i for that was I
at lunch you were off on in the most
expensive thing on the show floor he was
just he was just here and we found out
he was here and we're like you got to
come back and talk it was phenomenal I
mean this is I was reading the
black-and-white comic as a little kid
and then you know franchise keeps going
there's a new movie coming to Michael
Bay's producing the whole thing and then
Jim rash was around Dean Pelton from
community the archer panel was great
legend of korra season 2 they showed the
first episode for everyone there's just
been surprises all over the floor I mean
we've got wired staff is all over
we'vewe've blanketed the show super
jealous of your interviews but I got to
talk to the co-creators and writer
director of orphan black oh yeah super
awesome Rachel and also some of the cast
which is amazing I'm actually often
compared to buy some people on Twitter
uh to Kozma really yeah I think it's
probably cuz she's like a scientist the
word worst la no I hate to say this you
are one of two people here right now who
is often compared to her well I don't
want to brag I get that a lot who else
who else oh I got to talk to you the
cast of 300 rise of an empire Sparta
lots of ABS lots of abs yeah seriously
not all spray-painted on like mine um no
not at office ah i frankenstein oh that
was super fun also it feels like an
incredible day of comedy yeah for sure
for sure who did you talk to oh man Eric
Andre and Hannibal Buress Jim rash
obviously is big in the world of comedy
and you talked to the crew from NTS you
NTSF and he SF w AR p no no we got this
you got a be NTSF SD SUV
NBA no no SUV attended su Claire Claire
yeah and of course an old friend of mine
who I love so much i'm super looking
forward to the new show the kind of
revamp of cosmos of going out very neil
degrasse tyson NDG is a if there's a
real-life superhero who's a comic-con is
Neil deGrasse of course it is just the
fact that a scientist is so larger than
life is I loved him so much love that so
much yeah that's it it's a pretty full
day yeah and there's still two to go so
we got we got a lot anything in
particular that you're looking forward
to tomorrow or just seeing what the day
brings um hugh jackman over eens come in
yeah well rain is coming that's gonna be
you know I'm looking forward to all of
it i'm looking forward to going back out
on the floor i'm looking forward to
spending time at the wired cafe so much
to look forward to tomorrow we've got
way more awesome interviews i'm going to
go back to the floor maybe spend some
time in the wired cafe and of course
more giant robot all right we got two
more days to go so stay tuned we got a
lot more videos coming to wired so make
sure you keep watching on YouTube for
Cara Santa Maria special comic-con
reporter on Peter Ruben for Wired keep
watching it's Comic Con